[Music]  keep still if I were you right Manuel  shut down the crazy thing is happening  to me wake up and I don't know how I got  there the transmission failure huh you  have been experimenting those Bioware  technology your name is Ryan Reed you  probably won't come back but if you do  reboot only takes nine minutes and 47  seconds not minutes wait outside you  need to run now cuz if you see me again  it won't be meet you understand they own  you first of a new breed if you break my  toys let's simply be switched off I want  my life back  so are you  with a brand plan Ryan why are you  fighting  you're the one controlling  this thing that I've done to me they're  gonna do it to everyone know how you  control the masses fear  I know I need to  you may not understand this but our  ambitions are a little wider scope her  est pesticides plan oven in Atlanta she  didn't throw in distress we should eat  on the hydrastar Egon Kosma hands eh get  over her